bonjour et avec des mots bonjour selon
vous cette pandémie réveille la vieille
hostilité entre d'un côté l'état et de
l'autre côté ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les territoires oui ce qu'on
appelait les provinces jadis où les
régions enfin peu importe mais
effectivement c'est une vieille querelle
entre l'état central et les provinces et
et on a vu des scènes incroyables on a
vu l'état réquisitionné des masques ont
été commandés et payés par la région par
une région on a vu l'état a annulé des
décisions de mer qui voulait améliorer
le
le confinement par ap voilà donc on voit
des des présidents de région qui hurlent
en disant mais c'est scandaleux l'état
ne laisse rien faire ou un des maires de
grandes villes qu'ils disent mais
laissez-nous faire vous les tabous
savais rien faire et tout ça ddd des
scènes qu'on compte qu'on ne pensait pas
revoir
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait
c'est que l'état l'état en france l'état
qui est divisé en france pour des bonnes
raisons d'ailleurs puisque c'est lui qui
a fait le pays on oublie toujours c'est
l'état a montré son impéritie sa
désorganisation son incapacité à prévoir
à organiser et évidemment dans la
panique générale au moment où l'état
montre toutes ses faiblesses
et bien il y a à d'autres pouvoirs
qu'ils veulent montrer eux qui veulent
bien faire alors ils veulent montrer
pour des raisons de bonne volonté
d'abord pourquoi pour rendre service aux
à leurs concitoyens pour des raisons
électorales aussi où s'écrit municipales
sont pas fini puisqu'on n'a jamais fait
encore le deuxième tour et puis aussi
pour des raisons idéologiques car il ya
des vrais idéologues de la
décentralisation qui pensent que la
décentralisation ça serait mieux et
c'est dans cette crise l'état a quand
même montré ses faiblesses
alors vous qui êtes plutôt favorable à
un état centralisé plutôt qu'à la
décentralisation
ça doit vous faire réfléchir non non
parce que je pense que si vous voulez
nous sommes depuis 30 ans dans une
période transitoire
c'est à dire qu'on a
accru les fameuses lois de
décentralisation de 82 qui pour moi me
un désordre incroyable une gabegie
phénoménale une explosion de l'emploi
public
inutile donc ça envoie bien et en même
temps l'état qui résistent qui se
dépouille mais qui ne veut pas laisser
complètement ses pouvoirs voyez on est
dans une phase de transition qui ont été
beaucoup plus mieux réglée si on avait
gardé l'état d'avant les lois de
décentralisation
en tout cas c'est ce que je pense un
état qui était très efficace qui étaient
très compétents dans les alpes de
l'après-guerre et les années 70 on peut
pas dire que l'état a plié on peut dire
qu'il l'état a montré ses qualités on
voit que l'allemagne a mieux réagi que
nous dans cette pandémie du coronavirus
c'est quand même grâce à son système
fédéral
alors voilà c'est la vraie discussion
vous avez raison l'allemagne a montré
une efficacité remarquable une
prévoyance puisqu'ils ont beaucoup plus
de lits de réanimation que nous ils ont
tout de suite organiser les masques les
tests et c'est beaucoup plus que vous
avez tout à fait raison et c'est un
régime fédéral on l'a vu d'ailleurs
parce que dans le confinement qui était
beaucoup moins stricte que nous ils
n'étaient différents selon les régions
la bavière était plus au filet que
berlin vous avez mille fois raison
alors on peut dire c'est parce qu'ils
sont fédéraux sauf qu'à cela je vous
réponds l'italie et je vous réponds
l'espagne un pays aussi fédéraux que les
allemands même peut-être plus pour
l'espagne et qui sont une catastrophe
vous voyez bien que ce ne peut se dire
que c'est pas le critère est d'ailleurs
les italiens en voulaient beaucoup à
leur régime général il explique que que
c'est leur régime général qui a été la
cause des deux 2 une des causes en tout
cas parce que je pense que le la société
italienne est la plus vieille d'europe 1
plus vieille que les allemands je pense
que c'est une des raisons aussi pour
être honnêtes qui font que c'est là le
pays qui a le plus
plus payer le prix de cette de cette
épidémie mais à part ça voyez cdpi
régionaliste très fédéraliser l'espagne
faisait encore plus que l'allemagne et
c'est un désordre total et c'est une
impéritie pire que celle la française
donc voyez d'accès d'après moi c'est pas
le critère d'après moi le critère c'est
à la fois la culture c'est à dire on est
ravalé un pays méditerranéen et les pays
du nord s'en sortent beaucoup mieux tous
donc en fait selon vous la vraie coupure
elle ne serait pas entre d'un côté les
états centralisés et de l'autre les
nations fédéral mais plutôt entre les
pays du nord plus rigoureux plus
travailleurs qui auraient bien géré
cette crise et de l'autre côté les pays
du sud plus indolent je pense qu'il ya
de ça je pense que justement l'état golo
pompidolien nous avaient arraché à notre
destin méditerranéen par justement son
état c'est grand paradoxe de cette
discussion
et deuxièmement je pense que ce n'est
pas seulement la culture c'est aussi
l'industrie
c'est à dire qu'il ya des pays qui ont
concerné une industrie très forte
l'allemagne mais aussi la suède on voit
ils ont une industrie ils ont des choses
nous on a vraiment tout abandonner et on
voit le résultat est cruel
je pense qu'il ya ça aussi merci à
l'eczéma